twelve-year-old harlot still needs help
putting on her stilts they need to be
fastened tightly to her lower legs but
then together with her friends she can
walk around on them as if they were her
own legs Harley and the other children
here are refugees from Syria and Iraq
here in the Turkish border town of Magan
a group of Germans circus performances
getting them ready to give a show in
Istanbul Holly's life hasn't been the
same since they came the circus people
came to our refugee school and put on a
little performance they left us their
address the next day my brother and I
came straight here I was really excited
now I want to become so good that I can
teach other kids later on son Darmok and
lavish hepta ms amazing girl Michelle
holly is the only girl in the group her
teachers say she's a natural and can
take part in their performance in
Istanbul but here the children are
supposed to learn more than just how to
juggle and walk on stilts but one tree
hill feast yet Nick the aid we offer
isn't the big solution but a small one
for today 45 minutes an hour or a day to
work together with others and give
something to others that gives people an
incredible boost a lot of fun and energy
I could certainly use a boost madine
lies around 40 kilometres from the
Syrian border collie witnessed terrible
things as she fled from her home city of
Aleppo with her parents and siblings
three years ago
no no basho walk them all along the
route they were burned-out cars and
there was an explosion my brother
suffered minor shrapnel wounds in Aleppo
we couldn't sleep at night because of
the air raids that's why we fled if
Holly hadn't joined the children circus
she would have had to work at the market
in medina like hundreds of other refugee
children to supplement her family's
income now the circus pays our parents
enough to cover the lost wages because
Holly's parents are embarrassed by their
poverty they don't want us to visit
their home Ellen imagine an official my
parents aren't doing so well they have
no work and no money and they don't feel
at home in Turkey that's why they'd like
us to move to another country in the
evening Holly packs her bag for the trip
to Istanbul there the children will
attend a circus and hip-hop workshop the
boys are already warming up the
volunteer who supervises them says art
and culture are just as important for
poor children as financial support is
since they are the Caribbean mikichan
here they get a bit of the self
confidence they'll need to create the
life they want for themselves later on
culture should help children understand
the world around them that ultimately
people need more than just food and work
it's finally time to leave the Harley
and many of the other children it'll be
their first flight on an airplane it's
also the first time she's been away from
her parents for two whole days she's
really excited
two days later in Istanbul the city on
the Bosphorus Harley's been busy with
the workshop Germany's Goethe Institute
has bought the Syrian circus performers
together with underprivileged young
people from Istanbul this as their final
rehearsal with the Turkish German rap
group take your fate in your own hands
the young people sing when I'm
hip-hopping and rapping I just feel good
now along with the circus I've
discovered the music I like people will
make their soon then it's Showtime the
audience has captivated
on stage how they wrapped in Arabic
about peace courage and justice
for their encore all the young people
appear on stilts for Holly this night
was a big step towards a better life